this is obviously what we would be doing
next it's like
what we've learned from each other and
from our sessions together this is the
accumulation of like everything we've
been through filtered down into kind of
these little gold nuggets and we wrote
it because we love love like we just
love souls we just want people to
connect on that level we do couples work
and
and even with our kids or with our
friends it's like we want those deep
meaningful conversations you know we we
don't want to just kind of like how are
you doing on the surface i think we long
to be with people and meet
on that soul level so this book was our
attempt at
creating the map for that of like really
how do we get stuck or how do we stop
ourselves from that meeting place on an
ego level or just be in trauma or
attachment issues or
reactivity and then how do we really
just meet
and i think from that first paragraph
and the title of our book what we really
wanted to
speak to is that universal piece
like we didn't want this to be the book
for
some you know special people that are
into doing relationship work we really
wanted this to speak to that common
longing that i think we all have and
it's this and i wanted people to
recognize that in themselves
as they were reading the book
yeah like i wanted to ask the readers
can you recognize that part in yourself
that since the day you were born has
been longing to be met in unconditional
love and that doesn't mean just romantic
relationship but with with everyone in
in all interactions and uh that that
craving we have for authenticity
and and then examine really what is that
really why
why do we care why do we care if it's a
superficial interaction or an authentic
uh interaction
and
and what it comes down for
what for lisa and i and what we've seen
with clients is because there's
something inherent within us that wants
a soul to soul connection
and and that that's where we actually
grow and transform
and where we actually
meet each other and have can have
spiritual experiences within our
lifetime and that's why we chose that
word holy we actually had a couple
different titles we tried like the
mystics guide to relationships or the
souls guide to relationship and then
we're like you know we really want to
use holy on purpose because it's usually
just associated with these ideas of
religion or spirituality but we're look
kind of like what is love if not holy
and i think the reason people are
disappointed in relationships is because
that's the factor that's missing it's
more did i get what i thought i wanted
is it on my checklist of what i wrote as
what i wanted or am i
opening am i humbling that ego part of
myself and allowing the divine and
allowing love as an energy to be present
in my relationships and it's like any
type of
prayer you have to kind of start with
the intention and create the altar and
for us the altar is even the idea that
that's a possibility and then the energy
of love can come in and actually has so
much grace and changes the game in the
relationship if you invite that element
in but
your relationship says sacred i think
it's really
hard to do relationship work unless you
first bring in that element of viewing
it as sacred because then you can do
much deeper work
i feel like this is a that that
realization is a later part of the
process like in my mind at least in my
experience there's
childhood part there's understanding so
i think we'll start there and then
there's also sort of the self part in
trying to heal the aspects of yourself
to be able to receive it right to just
simply receiving love is not always
something people know how to do and so
let's backtrack and i might just sort of
touch on chapters but it might not be in
order here but i think that we start
with like what is it that what is it
that shapes us
um
like what happens in our childhood what
is the what is the what is the
progression that puts us in this place
where we
i feel like it's almost like life is
about this process of like
you know having bad operating systems
like you know you've got like aol dial
up and then
you
like get older and you're like this is
just not working and you're like it
works but not well and then you finally
have to figure out how to upgrade the
systems and so there's kind of like an
unlearning that happens and a
re-learning um or even a letting go is a
very much a part of it so
back to childhood what is happening that
makes us like we are yeah
well that initial longing that i was
talking about that i
believe we're all born with and i think
it's this blueprint to search for love
and to search for
for what's real in life
and so i think we all have that inherent
longing and i think that longing is for
a perfect love
but then we are searching for that
perfect love through imperfect people
and so and we're all imperfect you know
and we all have our our [ __ ] and our
wounds and sorry not not i don't know if
i'm allowed to swear on this or not uh
where are you like yeah great and that's
why we named the podcast holy and human
because we are very realistic about the
human part of that equation and
yeah the wounds attachment issues and
yeah so i think talk about that i don't
think that because i don't think that's
something people that always really know
about i don't think that's something
i mean even for me just realizing you
know in the last
six or eight years like in the last
three or four years how
pertinent and deep and
impactful
childhood programming and childhood
experiences are whether they're with
your family whether that's with some
crush that broke up with you and like
imprinted some traumatic memory of
something that where you learn to judge
yourself in some way or put yourself
down like there's so much stuff that
happens and you think as you go through
your life like it's you it's you it's
you and then finally you go it's me
every time every time every time
yeah so you know i think that's some i
really would love you guys to speak to
that that that part of us that that part
of us that gets programmed what happens
what's going on yeah well i think where
we really start the work with holy love
is first recognizing where we've been
disappointed in love
and where love has wounded us because i
think we need to face those things first
and be really crystal clear about what
that is uh because like i was saying
when we're searching for this perfect
love through imperfect people
it can be really
a common experience to start becoming
disenchanted with love and uh and have
wounds come up have negative
relationship experiences or have parents
that don't emotionally reflect us and
and things like that and so we be we can
become uh disenchanted and believe that
love itself
is a compromise that oh for me to be
loved in relationship for me to receive
this amazing gift of love i need to act
a certain way and you know i should be a
certain way i should be with this type
of person so we start ourselves putting
conditions on love we're like oh well
my past relationships have gone like
this so i need to act this way in my
next relationship or i won't get any
love
and like consciously consciously or
unconsciously is that happening yeah i
would say sometimes both i definitely
unconsciously but i think
we really
start
it's almost like we have no other data
except for our own experience so you
look at your past which is usually
you know fraud
with issues and then make predictions
based on what's happened
and
that's all coming from ego
like it's kind of like you can't solve a
problem from the energy level in which
it was created
right so it's like we're in beta state
and the ego and then we're trying to
make these predictions and assumptions
from
that place instead of understanding how
to actually connect to love as an energy
so that we raise the vibration and get
out of
all of those disappointments all of
those things that happened in childhood
we all have so much of that and it's
like they say
the first five years of your life are
the most important in your whole life in
terms of determining if the world is a
safe loving place if you're being seen
are you being
mirrored in that way and if you don't
get that you really do have to
consciously
do work
to fix
that time period in terms of your
nervous system in terms of being open to
love and i and it goes on
more than five i mean you know you've
seen us as parents we spend so we're so
aware i think we're almost sometimes too
aware
of that our impact as parents on our
kids
lives and so we are very intense on
ourselves in terms of parents of how do
we do today did we mirror their soul
um
because we know we're setting up their
orientation for all their relationships
and we've prioritized that over anything
else like over our career over financial
choices like that has been our top
thing because i just feel like if you
bring kids in the world and you
fail at that
it's to me it's the most important thing
well i think also when when we work with
people in sessions that's what we see
all the time is people that if they
haven't been emotionally met uh when
they're young that that's where we start
the work and so we have a big section of
our book that's dedicated to inner child
work and i absolutely love inner child
work because
uh
as you know as we work how we work with
saul is we encourage people to
intuitively connect to their eternal
self to their soul self
this is the part of them that existed
before they were born and that it exists
after they die and this is the part of
you that knows how to navigate love our
ego is not great at navigating love but
our soul
truly knows how to navigate love and
your soul is that source of
unconditional love
so every time we talk to our soul every
time we intuitively check in with our
soul we are in a way doing re-parenting
work because we're taking our lower self
our self that's believes in conditional
love and connecting to our unconditional
self and bringing that love
energetically down into the body and
having a healing experience through that
and most of us and we're not perfect
parents by any means but i think that's
how we orient what our goals are in
terms of our day and parenting is how
much was just doing and how much was
being how much were we present on a
being level because that's what really
that's what soul connection is and i
think what's amazing is how
much potential we have as humans if we
didn't get that golden ticket and our
parenting agreement
that we can still heal and
grow so much through our connection with
our soul and love and so it's kind of
like if you're listening and you didn't
have that amazing parenting and you're
hearing how impactful that is that might
be true and that might be why some of
your relationships have been harder but
it's not like a lost cause by any means
it's just kind of like now you get
to do that reparenting work and it's
actually
it sounds annoying like another thing i
have to do but it's actually so it feels
so good
yeah anytime you bring compassion and it
doesn't have to take forever you don't
need to spend years on that you know
sometimes you do i think uh
usually we don't heal in an instance you
know we kind of come back to an issue
and we keep uh working on it but uh soul
is as close as your next breath getting
that information from soul and getting
that information from what love would
say in this situation so often we see
when people really dial into their soul
that they get the intuitive information
how to move forward very quickly and i
see it like um when you're playing pool
no matter how bad it gets of if the
other person's winning the game's not
over till that next shot you always have
an opportunity to change the game around
no matter how late in the game it is
[Music]